can you uh uh talk about the box
oh yeah let me see
thank you
you came in with this box yeah yeah
lots of things in here
i'll put that down for now
first of all
there's there's a printer in this town
of los gatos
that makes these pads for me
pads of two dollar bills are they really
smell the ink yeah you can still smell i
think they're freshly printed they're
not real are they well hold on he gets
the supplies from a higher quality
printer
and they meet the specs of the us
government these bills and because they
meet the specs of the us government i've
looked it up they are legal tender i've
been spending them for like 30 years
and um i mean i don't know if it's the
right president
they want to get ink on me but um no
it's great and i sell a sheet of four
two dollar bills for five dollars
everywhere i go i sell lots of them and
because don't cost me eight dollars for
a sheet
and they're legal the secret service has
approved them i've had police called on
me a number of times the secret service
approved these bills
three times two of the times they
actually saw the bills
i don't know why it's only two times and
one time they read me my miranda rights
and when they read me my miranda rights
i should have brought it with me i used
um a fake idea that i made from back
when a personal computer could not print
a photo
could not print photo quality unless you
owned a real expensive dye sublimation
printer
to make backstage passes and all so i
have this i have this the id that i gave
the secret service says department of
defense but i respelled it defiant so i
could say it's a joke
not a fraud card
and it says i'm a laser safety officer
and i have an eye patch in the picture
laser safety officer that's what i gave
the secret service when they they knew
these bills were good they tested them
with the pen they'll pass the test
so you'll probably
want these i know steve has them but
i'll leave a few sheets here oh my god
oh look at that and if you look at the
serial number of this top one here it
ends you know 265
265 265.
um but they're the legal tender the
secret service is in charge of
counterfeit money
unreal can i show this on camera wow of
course you can smell it everything i
said is true except the president i know
it is the right president
um
it's amazing well
yeah looks great
all righty unreal my game boy
my game boy now they never sold this
model in the united states is from the
original original game boys with the
original original tetris cartridge
and this game boy lights up
it actually lights up
it was only sold in japan it was called
game boy light
and i still play tetris on it regularly
to just pass time when i want to
and one time i used to have always have
the high score on game boy tetris and
i'd send it into nintendo power magazine
back when you had to take real photos
and send them in the paper mail
and they said oh we your name's always
in there we want you we don't want to
print it anymore we're not going to
print your name anymore because we want
new people to get on the list
oh so i i did i took a picture of a high
score and i spelled my name steve
backwards is evidence and wozniak
backwards is kane zao
evitz kane zao
and then i thought if i put los gatos
they'll get suspicious it's the same guy
so i put saratoga california the next
city over and i sent it in and then i
forgot about it and i picked up this
nintendo power magazine
um one day and i flipped back to where
they have the scores and it's in here
but it prints that name everett's keynes
out and i saw it i didn't know it was
mine i'd forgotten i'd done it i said oh
my god a foreigner and he said saratoga
i got chilled he's nearby
and then and then i remember doing it
but so my name backwards is actually in
that magazine so you're still ranked for
your tetris score yes wow
well it was it was the highest that was
ever printed in nintendo power magazine
i don't play it anymore there's people
with sizes better than me i'm sure i
don't know um the highest one i ever got
i didn't send into them was in later
years i think it was
630
000 something like that my goal was 750
but never i'll never hit it
now this is a great mask of course
because everywhere i go this is the
number one mask everyone says oh i like
your mask i like your mask you know they
never do that every single place you go
so on airplanes i'd like to put this n95
over it
and then i'll
oh
it's a little tight i'll call a flight
attendant and i'll say
i want to inform you that for the rest
of this flight i'm going to take this
mask off
and and at first they're shocked and
accusing me you know and then they laugh
so laughter laughter is really worth it
you know now i used to go into janet
knight for quite a while wore
this type of face mask
hang on it might be trapped this type of
face mask
with a hepa filter
that you could wear you could wear on
the lanyard
that's great so you'd wear it you'd wear
it and you can turn it on to three
blowing levels
okay so sometimes when we're going to
the cigarette smoke or something jeff
janet's asthmatic this is a nice way to
get fresh air
fresh air through a through a fan that's
in here
and when i go into the stores like the
grocery store
um i would tell people a normal mask
isn't adequate for my condition
and they say what's your condition i'd
say geekiness
this this mask i've worn a couple of
times during the mask days
with something under and
i love this mask
[Applause]
wow it's also for geekiness
now we've got another type of peppa mask
hepa filter mask right here that just
goes on you
and it's also
filtered
yeah it's smaller and you got buttons
like a bane from batman now during the
the black lives matter protest i thought
if i ever heard of a protest around here
i might want to get in it so i actually
bought a real gas mask too but i never
used this in public to say this is my
this is my mask but i could
that takes care of my box wow that's so
great yeah
steve and i always joke about with the
time we got dinner and uh they came over
with the pepper and he said course and
then when they were done you said
fine i think about that once a week
that's amazing because just last night
we went out to dinner with
i don't know uh oh a friend a friend
from the masons i'm an honorary
california freemason for life wow i'm a
life member i'm not a mason as a person
is there a secret handshake not but i
went through a whole bunch of things
because my wife at the time was an
eastern star and then we could have more
joint
time together
is there there are secret words you have
to learn that i have no idea what i can
know you can never remember them it's
very difficult then you go up three
levels you're a mason for life and
everyone goes up to 33 levels not me i
dropped out because we got divorced
yeah and you probably played some tricks
on them but we were we were at the
restaurant yesterday the old spaghetti
factory
they brought up pepper and i did the
whole the standard thing or maybe it was
the night before somewhere and i said of
course
and then that's fine
whoever it was
it was actually at the grill on the
alley steakhouse and they were they were
actually kind of pleased with
the joke i'm sure fantastic and because
i do like course pepper
you know that's fine when i said of
course of course she unscrewed it to
make it coarse she realized she realized
it was more than just saying yeah sure
wow
i gotta say that every time i've ever
gotten together with you has just been
the most fantastic experience i value
our friendship beyond measure
yes and i decide the same absolutely
i'm a person that makes very very few
friends in my life you know every few
years i might make another one
that'll be a long-term friend
continually it's very rare
yeah well i'm not you're in there you're
the one i'm absolutely beyond grateful
for you and uh and and this time like
like always was very special and the
fact that we were able to record it and
share it with the world is even more so
so thank you the key people in my life
are creative people
and also especially comedians
magicians and the fact that you came to
my bucket list show and and actually
made it through to the end i i i oh no
no i understand comedy i was not against
that i was not disfavorable that's what
you that's what you do that's your
business oh no i understood it i told
julie that she she said that you thought
that somehow i was offended by it no no
i was just scared that you were gonna
see the things that i show at my bucket
list oh you gave me some no we took out
some really straight friends and i
started describing exactly what you've
done
oh wow man i love you steve and uh thank
you for this really looking forward to
the next time is there anything that we
can promote for you do you want to send
any traffic anywhere
i i never do i never try to promote
myself for anything he's like world
peace yeah world beast i probably did
the rescue rescue a dog and what is that
mask where's that face mask oh the
selfie mask
maskalike.com makes the best ones i
don't get anything to a mask i like
mask-a-like dolls don't make a mask that
looks like your face that looks like
your face you can also buy ones that
look like dogs and stuff sure i have
some of those i want a steve wozniak
mask okay that's upside down oh well
that would be a steve wozniak mask if it
were right side up
and i've ordered it i like dot com yeah
i think a couple more getting delivered
to our house in a day or two i love it
it's fantastic yeah it's fantastic and
i've only been wearing it for like three
weeks yeah every every single place
people say oh i like your mask
yeah well you said it okay
well
bless you steve and thank thank you so
much for this yeah everybody go to go
get something that matters home now
there you go
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]
you